i'd had this idea to create something
like a batman combat training guide so
if that's something you'd be interested
in then please leave a comment below so
that i know you're interested
[Music]
the news of the record-breaking turnout
though yet another story of the masked
vigilante known as the batman
[Music]
i'm vengeance
so here it is guys i'm very happy to
present the much requested much
anticipated batman combat training guide
the first video i created related to
this was the batman fight style video
earlier this year in which we explored
the different martial arts styles that
dart net has used throughout the many
depictions in which he's appeared so
there was so much stuff that could have
gone into this video but i wanted to try
to include things that people could
really implement at home without you
know having to require billions of
dollars to spend on gadgets and
technology so batman's purpose requires
a complete training program that
includes a vast array of different
techniques for various scenarios that he
finds himself in the video will be
broken down into a few different aspects
and i wanted to try to make it as
complete but also as applicable as
possible so firstly i'll give an
overview of why i've chosen to structure
the program in this way the next will be
a list of some techniques i've chosen
that batman utilizes including
demonstrations that can be practiced at
home then finally a workout plan in
which these techniques will be
categorized to be implemented at
different times including conditioning
drills and methods of training to go
along with them i've many based this
program on the version of batman that
appears in the arkham game series
because although it does contain some
physically impossible moves for us to be
able to train it is the most complete
and refined version of batman that we've
seen today so sometimes i'll be
referring back to that as well so let's
firstly talk about the fundamentals for
this and we can ask the question what
type of attributes are essential for
batman for his goals well the first
thing that came to my mind is that he's
almost constantly in life-threatening
situations and although he doesn't kill
people he literally has to incapacitate
his opponents quickly or lose his own
life basically and not only that but
remain composed as to do it multiple
times when against a gang for instance
so it's safe to say that he needs to get
through people fast is he's often got
multiple opponents to contend with so
stopping power is a big thing for him as
well as knowing where to actually hit
people
now for me in devising this program i
had to think about what it would be like
to be of a much larger heightened build
like batman and way smaller and would
generally move more like a nightwing
delivering multiple hits at speed rather
than some of the more favored knockout
blows that we see batman using so one of
the main things that batman needs to
focus on is his technique being
absolutely on point so that he can drive
the maximum power from his strikes which
is what i believe he would focus on
heavily as well as specific conditioning
work he would achieve this through
refining his technique and then working
upon specific strength and conditioning
which is why i recommend some dedicated
practice of the techniques in their most
basic form as i will demonstrate later
in order to refine this so not only does
batman require that big stopping power
but he also needs the endurance and
agility to be able to execute the
techniques against his opponents
effectively this balance can be
challenging to achieve and would be
different for each person depending on
their own individual attributes and it
can be difficult because certain
attributes are more conducive to
developing one of those areas say for
instance being leaner and lighter makes
improving agility and having greater
endurance easier to manage however too
far in that direction would then begin
to take away from the power batman needs
to be able to stop people quickly
conversely too far in the other
direction and focusing upon power more
exclusively runs the risk of neglecting
the development of agility so it's no
good to be able to deliver all of these
super quick strikes if they have no
stopping power behind them and no good
having all this power if you can't move
in and out of the danger zones quickly
enough to minimize taking too much
damage for this reason there will be
recommendations to work on different
elements of training at different
intervals one thing i've noticed is that
batman employs a common sense and
adaptable approach when he's in combat
situations meaning that once he's
delivered an attack he tends to use the
most direct and simple attack on the
subsequent enemy as he often doesn't
have the option to say reset his stance
after beating one person up so he has to
be very adaptable and fluid which
indicates he would have a lot of moves
in his arsenal this is naturally
something that's going to be very
difficult to train without having
multiple opponents but is a principle
that can be kept in mind when working
out like this for instance although
these are both valid this combo
utilizing a jab rear elbow body shot and
rear round kick requires a little less
movement and is more logical than say
executing a jab cross rear elbow lead
leg switch kick this approach can also
be applied to individual motions as well
such as going straight from a cross into
a same arm elbow strike by simply moving
in and shortening the distance between
you and the target and before we get
into it guys you can subscribe to my
youtube channel and follow me on
instagram and feel free to message me if
you have any questions about the program
and i'll do my best to help you out i've
also created a download of the workout
that is linked in the description below
but that will make more sense at the end
of the video
so just to recap on batman's martial
arts background as we discussed in the
predecessor to this video we can
determine that his base style was boxing
that he learned from ted grant and we
also know that he's a master of 125
martial art styles and underwent
extensive training with the league of
shadows as we saw in the nolan
depictions all of this culminates in the
description that his primary form of
combat is an idiosyncratic admix of
taekwondo muay thai judo kickboxing
karate boxing jiu jitsu and ninjutsu
there's also weaponry in there as well
but this video won't cover that aspect
as it's not really an area that i'm
familiar with so there's a hell of a lot
to contend with them for this reason i
want to cover any potential comments
that people may make that i should have
included xoy et cetera i've had to make
decisions about what to include and what
to leave out of the video as i'm sure
you as the audience are able to
understand before we get into it i want
to touch on a very relevant point which
to my knowledge has had little to no
representation in any of the batman
media i've encountered outside of the
brief element of it represented in
batman begins during his league of
shadows training and that is sparring we
usually see an already established
batman fighting against criminals and
sure this would be great real world
practice but it would be too risky for
him to rely solely on this area for his
training in reality bruce would need
continuous sparring practice against
very high level martial artists to
ensure that he was keeping his skills
homed and on top of that against
multiple opponents as well however that
would then run the risk of people
finding out his secret identity so
there's also that to contend with i
think this is a big hole in the batman
mythology personally that i would love
to see addressed in future depictions so
for this reason sparring training is
included in the training program and i
understand that this may not be possible
if you don't have anyone to train with
so if that's the case then you can
double up on one of the other elements
as you see fit and lastly something i
considered is the idea that bruce would
be likely to perform his training
wearing the full bat suit as this is the
attire he wears out in the field so the
audience may wish to wear heavy clothing
or even something like a weighted vest
for some elements of the program if they
wish to potentially stimulate the added
weight of the bat suit and gadgets that
bruce has to take into account so let's
begin with the fundamental techniques
then that will be separated into
specific categories
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so we've come to the workout section now
which will utilize many of the elements
already showcased the workout is based
on a four day on one day off schedule
and for that reason i haven't specified
any certain day of the week for the
program to be implemented just begin
whenever you can the program is
structured in a way that covers a broad
range of elements that are essential to
batman's training in combative arts i'll
give a description of each now and then
afterwards i'll give a full list of the
workout at the end as mentioned i
understand that some of this stuff
requires a partner and specific
equipment that may not be accessible for
everyone but this is just a sample
workout so implement what you can and
switch out other stuff if needed either
way this is all useful stuff to know and
you can always implement new things in
the future
[Music]
day one is technique practice firstly
warm up and get loose using the agility
ladder or a jump rope for one or two
rounds next you can choose to do the
technique practice in a number of ways
those being used in various types of
training bags pads or shadow boxing or
any other methods of your own choice but
the focus is on technique these rounds
of course will double up as
activity-specific conditioning with the
body adapting specifically to the
activity being performed firstly get
into your flow by implementing two
two-minute rounds of shadow boxing
varying in pace then begin using your
training tool of choice for eight to ten
two-minute rounds aiming to implement
techniques that were demonstrated
previously we're looking for speed and
accuracy on this day with moderate power
as there's another technique they joined
the program which will focus more on
power exclusively
[Music]
day two is stand-up sparring for
sparring practice it's important to work
with somebody who you have a mutual
agreement about the goal of this
practice working with some eager maniac
who just wants to take your head off
isn't going to enable you to learn so
work with somebody with a decent level
of skill and control we're gonna do ten
two to three minutes sparring rounds
rounds one to four will be light and
technical as you'll be getting into the
flow and the first few rounds of
sparring are always a little more tense
and less fluid so use these to warm up
and work on some tactics and defense
rounds five to ten will be similar but
at a faster pace with a little more
power aim for around 50 to 60 power
[Music]
day three is a bodyweight conditioning
circuit the way this works is as follows
there are two sets with four exercises
each and you want to do these at speed
repeat each of the exercises for 30
seconds without a break until you've
completed all four which reaches a total
of two minutes then rest for 30 seconds
and repeat this again for a further two
rounds rest in 30 seconds between each
once you've finished the first round
then move on to the next set with four
different exercises and do the same
thing over again
[Music]
do
after finishing as a bonus you can work
with a partner to condition your body to
take certain strikes assume the hollow
position for 20 to 30 seconds while your
partner delivers moderately powerful
strikes to your abs continuously for two
rounds next stand up and place your
hands behind your head and have your
partner deliver punches to your oblique
area for twenty to thirty seconds with
moderate power continuously day four is
grappling practice firstly we're gonna
do two three minute rounds training a
mixture of wrestling and ground
techniques with a partner again work
with somebody who understands the aim
and is not a savage who's just going to
ragdoll you around next we're going to
do two to three two minute rounds of
grappling only sparring i've used some
of my friends for these clips because
grappling really isn't my area and i
wanted to leave it to people who knew
better about it than i did day five is a
complete rest day or you can do some
active recovery
day six is technique practice once again
warm up like before with the ladder or
jump rope followed by the shadow boxing
rounds then using your training tool of
choice to do the work once again however
today we'll focus more upon powerful
blows for six two to three minute rounds
don't worry about stringing together
long combinations here it's more about
training to apply power to individual
strikes or short combinations
day seven is sparring practice once
again today's sparring practice is a two
to three minute sparring rounds like
before rounds one to four will be
technical to get into a flow then rounds
five to eight we want to apply a bit
more power and intensity into the
strikes so you want to get stuck in with
your opponent a bit more on the later
rounds but still keep your composure and
control throughout if it's applicable
you can also do full mma sparring here
using mma gloves so that you can both
strike and grapple simultaneously
[Music]
so that was the last day of the program
but tomorrow you will begin again with
day one adhering to the four day on one
day off split and lastly i'm gonna
include a few striking combos that i put
together utilizing the techniques as a
bonus section because it didn't really
fit with the flow of the video once it
came to editing so those will be shown
now
so combo number one is the tornado elbow
strike followed by a lead body shot to
lead hook ending on a rear round kick
combo number two is a double jab cross
jab and we push back on that jab to a
jump spinning back kick
[Music]
combo number three is a rear body shot
to lead hook followed by a rear elbow to
the same pushing back jab as the
previous combo followed by a spinning
back kick
combo number four is just a simple rear
round kick to spin back kick or spin
hook kick
[Music]
combo number five is a jab cross to same
arm elbow at the same time transitioning
forward into southpaw followed by a back
fist into a tornado kick
combo number six is a jab cross at the
same time transitioning forward into
southpaw delivering a circular downwards
elbow to a same arm push elbow finishing
on a spinning elbow
combo number seven is a jab cross hook
coming through the target then
delivering a back elbow strike with the
same arm finishing on a spinning elbow
and combo number eight is starting in
southpaw we're going to do a shoot
forward jab to close the distance
followed by a same arm body shot rear
leg round kick and then finishing on a
retreating superman punch
so we've reached the end of the video
guys i really hope you enjoyed it and
it's giving you some things to implement
as mentioned you can get a download of
the workout below so you don't have to
keep referring back to the video all the
time and please follow me on youtube and
instagram where i'll do my best to
respond to any questions you may have
about the program thank you guys and
i'll see you in the next video
[Music]
you